tsg hier setzt im prinzip auf die
richtigen themen also wohnungsnot
lehrermangel lohndumping wo er
vielleicht noch ein bisschen luft nach
oben hat ist der ganze bereich
schlagfertigkeit ich glaube das ist
einfach nicht akzeptabel ist dass leute
hier wirklich teilweise monatelang in
ihren lkws leben und da muss was
passieren
was muss passieren das ist eine gute
frage
ja das steht ja immer noch auf dem acker
meine damen und herren und grübelt vor
sich hin
tsg ist ohne frage ein anerkannter
steuer und finanzexperte den man
wahrscheinlich viel zu oft unterschätzt
absurd es aber auch wenn sogenannte
expertin für körpersprache versuchen was
in den thorsten rhein zu lesen was da so
eigentlich nicht ist bei thorsten
schäfer gümbel brands ihnen drinnen und
das sehen wir das war jetzt
wahrscheinlich zu schnell schauen was
uns vielleicht noch mal in der zeitlupe
an da wird man mal was seinen
augenbrauen etwas genau sehen dann merkt
man ganz schön louis der lässt nichts
anbrennen
nur ein gott ist der aggressiv oder
haben sie schon mal so brutale
augenbrauen gesehen das ist ja total
wohl hier guck mal absolut absolut
legendären testosteron thorsten
durchdrehte ja seine parteigenossen
nennen ihn inter nur noch gut aber aber
der gingko ist gar nicht das problem
die bundes-spd nahles und co die ziehen
denn bruno mit runter weil sie immer
noch glauben sich in der groko erneuern
zu können
gleichzeitig sorgen die grünen den sozen
auch in hessen die wähler ab die grünen
wie machen die das
wenn politik durch immer nur so einfach
wäre meine kollegen wollen die grünen
haben äpfel verteilt jetzt will sie grün
apple der wählerwille äpfel
wenn man erhält man aber auch drauf
kommen können oder da verteilt die
jahrelang kugelschreiber plötzlich
wollen die leute äpfel das kann doch
nicht wahr sein
ja die grünen hier haben in hessen mit
der cdu tatsächlich relativ geräuschlos
regierten sagt man es immer geräuschlos
und werden dafür gehabt während die
union der seniorpartner kämpfen muss in
hessen
deswegen heißt die wahl am sonntag bei
vielen ja auch die heiße schlacht am
kalten buffet das ja mein gott wir
kommen wirklich in die wortspiele das
ist ja unglaublich
seine cdu ist in den umfragen zwar
stärkste partei sogar mit abstand aber
deutlich schlechter als vor fünf jahren
der volker der freude der fed von
morgens bis abends allerdings
hinterlässt der wahlkampf auch bei ihm
so langsam spuren da ist finde ich so
eine gewisse müdigkeit
wir müssen uns besonders um die
internet-kriminalität kümmern
und nach wie vor um die gefahren des
extremismus und des totalitarismus
ich habe sowas von kein bock mehr
backwaren
so aber eins hier eins muss man dem volk
hier lassen er redet im gegensatz zu
anderen nieder afd nach dem mund das ist
heutzutage leider nicht mehr
selbstverständlich
außerdem hat er einfach eine geile
stimme oder das letzte was wir in hessen
gebrauchen können wäre eine linke
regierung geil oder für das saubere
musste schon ein paar hundert stangen
brot händler weg warten
und wenn sie jetzt sagen wir mal die
stimme kenne ich doch völlig richtig das
letzte was wir in hessen gebrauchen
können wäre eine linke regierung gehe
ich rede ja bleibt volker bouffier
scherrer von hessen hochdramatische wahl
jedenfalls vor allem für angela merkel
erscheint einmal live vors kanzleramt
nach berlin zu ulrich von heesen ulrich
wie sehr muss die kanzlerin den zittern
übermorgen das ist auch alles nur absurd
welche jetzt hängt das schicksal der
republik plötzlich an hessen waren
hessen ganz hinten dem odenwald wohnen
leute die haben vorfahren mit mehr als
zwei beinen
komm komm demokratie halt aber klar für
merkel wird es gegen jens spahn kommt
zweimal am tag mit dem zollstock in ihr
büro und überlegt wo er seinen
schreibtisch in stellen aha also der
sparen ist für sie der natürliche
nachfolger keine ahnung
da wird ja im moment praktisch jeder
gehandelt sogar unser seriöses zdf
spekuliert wild vor sich hin
längst ist merkel in der cdu nicht mehr
alternativlos noch wagt sich keiner
offen aus der deckung noch erklärt sich
keiner zur gegenkandidatur bereit
der ausgang der landtagswahl in bayern
essen spielt da eine entscheidende rolle
ja ist ja nicht so dass die cdu keine
guten leute hätte bis jetzt verstecken
die feiglinge sich noch in ihren löchern
aber wenn hessen fällt dann ist
alarmstufe rot auf ein paar wie an
felsen ja was kann die merkel denn
machen um das ruder noch rumzureißen
ja da hatte sie diese woche wirklich
eine fantastische idee weil ja frankfurt
in frankfurt fahrverbote drohen sie aber
nach wie vor die autoindustrie nicht
traurig machen möchte hat sie sich
gedacht scheiß drauf gesetzt kann man
doch umschreiben
wir glauben dass in der regel
fahrverbote nicht verhältnismäßig sind
wenn es sich um grenzwert
überschreitungen von geringerem umfang
also bis zu 50 mikrogramm pro kubikmeter
handelt wir wollen hierzu das
bundesemissionsschutzgesetz also die
entsprechenden gesetze ändern so nämlich
wenn mir ein gesetz nicht passt da
machen wir neues dirty von der art
kleiner haken der bouffier hat
inzwischen festgestellt dass speziell
frankfurt doch mehr als 50 mikrogramm
hat schön auf kies gefüllt aber die
geste zählt ja die sollen sich endlich
ernsthaft mit der autoindustrie anlegen
mein gott bis zu 5000 euro strafe könnte
man verhängen für illegale abschalt
einrichtung und zwar pro fahrzeug ja
aber es wäre gemein das tust du leuten
nicht an die dir ständig so nette briefe
schreiben auto lobbyisten schreiben
direkt an die liebe angela und der chef
des kraftfahrt-bundesamts schließt
mitteilungen schon mal mit
industriefreundlichen groß
autonomie ist ein dutzend unsere
kanzlerin was sagst du dazu nicht mal
ihr mann darf die duzen
aber was wenn ich find's super die liebe
angela sagt und ich zitiere in geringem
umfang gegen gesetze verstoßen ist ab
sofort erlaubt
das hat sich glaube ich so nicht gesagt
doch doch und ich fange mal direkt damit
an kokain in geringen mengen in geringem
umfang weinort und ist man schon
zuhälter wenn man gerade mal zwei
minuten am laufen hat
ich meine nein und jetzt freunde gehen
wir drei hübschen mal eine bank
überfallen aber nur in geringem umfang
zu abflug mädels
[Applaus]
[Musik]